[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais le problème c'est que blanchi les
bassins les gens savent que je ne vous
écoute pas ce avec la reine d'angleterre
delà et sakassou pas franchement on sait
pas c'est pas la meilleure des amis et
des rédactions
si la france
et oui l'ont fait mais oui ils l'ont
fait ils sont en ligue 2 derrière moi
ils l'ont fait chambly est en ligue 2
bravo à chambly ils l'ont fait et
l'année prochaine elle sera à beauvais
pour 15 mac abonnés 4 à charléty
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
triton cadeaux et maintenant il faut que
je vous montre c'est que la supportrice
de l'om m'a rapporté alors qu on est
bien d'accord que je mens cac du foot
droite au but
ils sont au courant qu'il faut en mettre
ou pas des piétons
[Applaudissements]
denis balbir ya giovanni castaldi sava
certains ragots jean philippe goron et
willaert l on est là habillés en
couleurs de l'oeuvre on se calme et
frappent hawaii qui s'est passé hier je
crois que vous avez perdu compris je
fais la mission avec ton stylo
franchement je tenais rien foutu m'en
fous mais ça me fait trop c'est trop
mignon
on est sorti des studios et notre libido
bélie national est en train de prendre
des petites photos donc l'arrivée de
ludovic rideau les tories en mode
hôtesse de l'air la john lennon elles
sont géniales cette rose elles sont
extraordinaires là à saint paul